アーサー
[拍手]
こんにちはー2019年最後の動画になります
皆さん今年も始シャツを本当にありがとうございました
今どんな1年だったんでしょうね今年はもうこういう総集編の動画だすのを4回か5回
狙いなってると思うんですけど
まあ今年もいろいろ今年あってもいろいろなかったらを
マリ特に江津面的なダイバー月的な映像することもなく結構あのさっといけたような気
がしました
たくさんの方にお世話にあった1年だったと思います見て下さった皆様
お仕事一緒にしてくださった皆さん本当にありがとうございました入れ歯って感じです
ね今年は
そんなこと実演の動画まとめましたのでぜひこんなこともあったなーこんな動画を見
たいなということで振り返った az ずつ月
どうぞ
私肇社長は
今年1年
頭しかしません
[音楽]
par rar
rar
ああああああ
えっなにこれ
わー
けれど覚えられん
ああああああ
wh
voodoo はい
re ああああ
[音楽]
you are
うまいかどうかは別の話でパンでいた通りらー
かみっわー
489万円600系なんか前でございます
はあああ
[音楽]
ni
me
[音楽]
amara
rar
バーガー ran
itano ああああふわぁ
特技が節一家の車やっほ
[音楽]
ni
いたずらされておったぞなんだわなぁやー
1号室とにボスの壁をブチ壊すことは可能でしょうか
どうぞ ok するん ano デー
goo
としてですね最後に今後の目標について聞かせてください
それから徐々に地球の生活に慣れていったんだこいつとらー
もう仲良しそのこれコンビでこれぞれぞれ
脳天チョップ一発で瀕死状態だ
じゃーん
俺がノートを使ったのはバケツっ
a 賞だったあああ
rar
ana はっはっは
あああああっはぁん
[音楽]
me
はあああああああ
ああああああ
saranam
le
rar
ana
[音楽]
re
ライダーをしました
はぁ
yeah
ああああああん
goo
tee
[音楽]
ザーン
ジャンを預かって
んわふーちょっと本気だしたら
本文カラー
ああああああ
[音楽]
ガー透けちゃったああああ
この家には変わっていた
me
グルーポねございます
[音楽]
ni
rar
re te ki ni
あっひどいだった兄弟0
[拍手]
[音楽]
ええええええええええええええええ
wh
ana le
p 2使ってコーラでございます以上ずっと
てみようと思いますきっと1位とビット1リピーター法令ワイルドいえーい
ああああああああああああ
てきたことがあるんです割れない応援歌 le
俺もれれ事例でオレオレ音れるうえでオレオレ
わけわからんじゃぞい
[音楽]
male
ああああああ
ran
ni
ビリー
水けジェイガードって何 p 思いません真鍮色
ウィンズ呼び今はんけどなぁ
もどってくださいねーん
ame
んあー ano hi ni
入れてかかったでしょうか2019年見てもらった通り全部数字で同じ服
映像的で変化が非常に薄かったなと思ってこの1年スーツを着続けて失敗したなと思い
ましたよなんか初心は忘れずね
動画とることができたねそこは良かったなと思い
2初診のホーローの大切さをわかりつつもいろんな服を着る大切さもまたまだ1年だな
と思いますね
だけで来年も宜しくお願いしますじゃ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ